citation needed joining me today he
reads books you know it's Chris Joel
more of a value pack with each passing
year I kissed a girl and I liked it you
say god yes that was the joke just just
enunciate them I'm the Bounty's man on
the Internet Matt gray I didn't come up
with anything to say here from Wikipedia
and these folks can't see it every fact
right is a point and a ding and the
special prize for particular dancers
which is
and today we are talking about the
Norwegian butter crisis of all the
crises up there with Cuban missle always
find I can't believe it it's not a
margarine crisis that actually clarifies
what I was going to ask what you just
slid into that one the Norwegian butter
crisis was it a crisis involving butter
in Norway have a point for that but I'd
like a bit more is that bit like an
essay question where you just repeating
the type now the question I have to try
and think of the answer of is did they
have too much or too little the question
was too much or too little too much too
little exactly the right amount so if
there's a butter crisis does that mean
there's a milk crisis going on as well
because you come from milk yes it does
yeah you don't get a point for butter
coming from but yes
heavy rains during the summer affected
the grazing of cows and reduced milk
production so what happens if there is a
shortage of butter you buy butter from
somewhere else
toast is awful yeah I were the top wit
song basic supply and demand here there
is less butter therefore butter is more
costly and only available to the crowned
heads of Europe I mean I didn't even
point to the first Norway was gripped by
small panic which translates as so more
panic
but yes configure of like a Norwegian
palates go which is no panic Somali so
yes it got to the point where a single
pack of imported Lurpak butter o cost oh
you know we get to Price is Right rules
here here is a pack of butter in mid
December 2011 unsalted it does not
specify does it depend on my use
unsalted that's my your bakers who are
gonna be throwing money at it oh no this
is this is very much
dietary butter diet diets butter there's
a butter diet now I quote slice it light
cheese and put it on toast
one thousand kronor chrome is about
hundred quid I think yeah that's that's
more less hundred pressure one second
I'm gonna say the equivalent of 25 quid
I was gonna say a hundred kid but he's
already got that so let's say a hundred
and fifty pounds or 1500 kronor
Gary is correct 32 pounds the same as
you paint a nose now follow
so why did this not get resolved by by
the three hand of capitalism because the
three hand of capital is my too much
butcher on it was all slippy and
contributive fingers of capitalism just
something wrong with the world
why do they not just import more butter
tariffs yes cause cause not in EU yes
topical hold on everybody radio get the
big reel-to-reel recorder is running
we're coming yes
tariffs on butter there was a deficit of
500 to a thousand tons of butter in the
country a shipping container they can
see over the border in Sweden Norway all
of it Hayes around that region I don't
know who's next - what
surely that affected Sweden as well
because the weather should be similar
around there right you say that
what did some swedes do did they taunt
them on the border by teasing really
thickly buttered toast post butter over
the border smugglers yes not butter a
number of individuals were apprehended
by the authorities for attempting to
smuggle butter across the border while
Swedes posted online adverts offering to
drive butter to Norwegians
did they get around the custom by
greasing their palms no a Danish
television show also broadcast something
television learn to be more specific
with my question they just have some
slow TV Norway style both just butter
melting in a kitchen why so much of
course even water waste
sad chefs with empty pounds go looking
little big puppy-dog eyes and going if
only I had some butter you know what yes
they broadcast a satirical emergency
appeal - Sam Botta
there are people without butter in this
country they gathered 4000 packs to be
distributed to butter starved Norwegians
there's a lot of very dark stuff in here
but there is also the Ark of taste what
it's not like the Ark of the Covenant
but with with tasty treats don't look at
it just comes flying is it an
institution kind of thing that is a a
catalog of national tastes so would it
have the fermented fish ikana thing in
it almost as one word you're missing in
there which is yes it's a catalog of
international foodstuffs and tastes and
things like that
extinct no longer culturally dying out
like Welsh died out that sort of Daddy
endangered heritage foods so is it all
stuff that people either can't be asked
to make anymore they've decided it's not
good for you and it's gone out of
fashion kind of stuff and then
everyone's forgotten about it yeah
pretty much you may not be forgotten
about but it could be all rules have
presented it being done like
unpasteurized milk that kind of thing
does they want to name some of the
things that in the United Kingdom
session of the architraves just in terms
of categories it's not exact things what
are we famous for historically Cornish
Pasties now they're fine aren't they
there's loads those we've learn York
station this morning just lying there
some kind of cheese yeah it's mostly
cheeses and grains that's the history of
Britain right there why great do all
they were cheese and grains and potatoes
potatoes any specific famous potatoes
you might know King Edward Maris Piper
you're just naming potatoes now is the
point the Kohinoor potato that sat in
the Royal Crown open til 16 for until
the English Civil War okay the middle of
the English code of things put in it
Jerzy royal is endangered it is listed
here as being this this endangered thing
I smell bullsh
no in there no no not in there Sam there
is old gossipy old luster beasts
arguments in old Gloucester Gloucester
beef when there's only one piece of
cheese like um on radio for come on we
also have under food politics the
British restaurant that from I saw sorry
I saw your face go down that was the
face of Garry going I have remembered an
archive can I just tell you one of my
things I'd like to get out and this read
us yes they may be reading that board
they've all got book not every fact
comes from it intelligent things this is
from Dad's Army the British restaurant
was a national restaurant in the Second
World War that's so cheap and cheap and
good food to people yes soldiers
absolutely right it was a government it
was originally a community feeding
Center decided that British restaurant
was brandy cheese we also have the
category here in Wikipedia of butter
there is an entire a salon Lurpak there
is also an entire article on someone
called Norma Lyon ly Owen she's American
farmer and an artist who painted him
bought to her or carved into butter yes
[Music]
yes born in Nashville Tennessee what
kind of things did she carve out of
butter president's faces cubes
bricks
the drawers made a brick well this was a
specific thing at the Iowa State Fair
and has been ever born it's all it's
very apt that you would carve this out
of butter yes the Iowa State Fair butter
cow taking their piss a little bit isn't
it well we're taking the milk but did
they carve a specific cow or just the
generic concept of cow a cow or do the
carve Daisy all right so the specific
cow are just like an outline of you know
cows so Daisy can look at butter Daisy
made from Daisy's butter no it was a
generic cow but there are also some
other topical things that are carved
alongside it a milk urn no topical for
whatever was going on in the world that
year a tank yeah basically what I have
for a list here is everything since 1996
every year since 1996 they've carved
something carved both both the butter
cow that's been since 1911 a 96 has been
something else that was mr. blobby know
some of the things include Tiger Woods
he won the golf something that's
definitely just a cigar yes ah no that
that year um what he was that good great
that'll be about 19 I'll know 90 silver
got around at 96 97 no an American Eagle
was and in 2007 Harry Potter
Wow Harry butter Harry butter Harry
butts to the cow all right there is one
last thing I want to talk about in the
category of butter great this is the
butter episode and I would like us to
talk
about artificial butter flavoring just
don't god you sound like this chair at
an agricultural conference I'm finally
delegate so he's one thing I would like
to talk about the scourge of artificial
butter flavor crusty buttery the thing
is it is a scourge it is a scourge is
actually a pretty good word for this
things that calling themselves butter
when they aren't really butter but
they've got pretend butter in them yeah
it's butter flavoring that goes into
other stuff it is butter flavoring and
that's from the new BBC two series
William Shakespeare food analyst
including a very modern bit of
technology via iPhones no we're looking
for something pretty modern technology
that's that's used by a lot of people on
dubs buttery condoms now I've seen
whisky flavored and smoky bacon flavored
ones in pubs that be possible
those are the crisps Gary the thing
you're going to in the bathroom to get
you crisps from they're not crisps
that's where the kid came from
this is something that is causing her
lung problems
yes siree a buttery vape popcorn
flavored vapor butter and popcorn flavor
vapor was a thing for a while and now
they are trying to sell it without these
chemicals in but that that is vaporizing
some liquid so can you just put butter
in it use aerosol butter yeah spreadable
that's that's more liquefied isn't it
yes yeah yeah more oils though you gotta
be careful I don't think inhaling actual
butter Idzik is any better than inhaling
diacetyl fumes ah but is it tastier
there's only one way to find out folks
and why didn't that flavoring that
marjorine everything like that why
didn't that solve the Norwegian butter
crisis but it's dreadful yes that is
actually the case
marjorine if you ever seen its natural
form is really on appetites just a gray
lump isn't it an affray is colored
yellow so it looks more like butter and
therefore an appetizer yeah you're
absolutely right margarine was such a
poor substitute by Norwegian standards
that they went out and bought the butter
instead and I have lower standards than
Norway and what year was this 2011 oh so
that was still when you could get
reasonable butter substitute yes it is
still definitely a substitute it is
still definitely a substitute and that
was why there was Smurf Anik butter
panic in Norway and that's what the
Smiths song panic is about panic in the
streets of Oslo Morrissey will be
enjoying that because he's learning here
is that Marcy cause of the buttock fries
I'm not congratulations Matt you in the
show yeah you win a chocolate bar shaped
like a cartoon frog that is also the
lead singer of a queen tribute act I've
got this Gary Fredrik Yuri say thank you
to Chris you're drowning tomorrow Scott
we'll see you next time
[Music]
you